yellen what was yellen's uh prior job
what was her job before uh her
uh current job she was chairman of the
fed right so here's here's what happened
with yellen and then we'll go into
what powell said if you want to go to
page seven page seven janet yellen
she also got a million dollars from
melvin capital by the way
to to make sure that uh gme didn't uh
bankrupt them but that's a whole
different thing so let me read this
story
uh uh where's ch consulting leave me
alone on page seven or six let me see
janet yellen says page seven but i don't
see it on page seven where
is janet yellen story kai
oh let me see here i don't see it on
seven
six right here okay but it says seven on
the paper just so you know that kind of
is it on page nine with bad haircuts
there we go okay six so janet yellen
to take extraordinary measures to
prevent u.s from debt default this is a
newsweek story
treasury sector secretary janet yellen
says she will take
extraordinary measure to prevent the u.s
from a default on a national debt unless
congress asked to suspend or increase
the debt limit she warned
congressional leaders in a letter friday
in a letter to house
speaker nancy pelosi yell and put
lawmakers on notice that the treasury
department will end the
end at the end of july suspend the sale
of bonds the avenue by which the u.s
finances its
debt obligations for two years the debt
limits have been suspended currently the
debt bound by the limit
is point 20.4 trillion dollars the debt
default has never been permitted by the
government white house secretary jim
sackey
told reporters friday saying the
possibility would be a catastrophic
event yellen said a default would cause
irreplaceable harm to the us economy and
the livelihoods
of all americans tom what's your
thoughts on this this is a cut and paste
headline that every three years shows up
and then he just raised the ceiling
and they sit there and they debate it
and then nobody wants to be the first
person to the floor of the congress
remember congress is the purse senate
is the approval and nobody wants to be
the one that raises it
you've remember this so so i i think
this is
this is right on time every three years
they have to act responsible
and they're telling you're they're
freaking out average
americans saying default oh my gosh
what's going on here and then they're
just going to take a stroke of the pen
and they're going to raise the ceiling
we could go back and google this three
years ago and you'll find similar
headlines
and nobody wants then mitch mcconnell
didn't want to be the guy that
authorized it because he didn't want to
get pinned
you raised the debt you raised the debt
because there's always an election
coming
nixon took us off the gold standard
tommy had one famous quote and it's
we're all kenzians now
we're all kenzians now dude what what
it's a hal holbrook quote from the
original wall street movie
i haven't seen things this bad since
that bastard nixon took us off the gold
standard there you go
you remember that we're all kenzians man
so dude th this is
this is p like the fiat currency that
that we're working off of right now it's
so it's so disappointing man because
what did we just get for the stimulus to
bail out what how much
money does it cost to run our country
right now they they can't run it on five
trillion
they can't run it on eight trillion but
it's okay let's raise the debt limit
because if we give them 10 trillion
dollars of our money guys
they'll get it they'll nail it at 10
trillion i'm sure they'll be responsible
on this next batch
of stimulus qe 55 whatever it is
quantitative easing forever
they took all the money they shut us
down they took all our money and they
gave it to all their buddies
and now they're saying i don't know what
happened all the money guys we're gonna
default
you gotta give us some more of your
money otherwise ah it's gotta be
catastrophic
man oh man i got to tell you man we are
we are entering the
the the the sherwood forest phase of the
american economy we are just getting
ripped off by the people that are
supposed to be can you pull out the
power story
pull up the palster because these two go
together so here's powell
fetz powell feels heat from all sides as
inflation spikes both the fed and biden
administration have paid
rapid price increasing or being stoked
by temporary factors
what was the comment that he made this
is politically using the word spikes
powell warned lawmakers on wednesday
that inflation is likely to remain high
for months
before cooling down in the wake of
hotter than expected price increases in
may and june but he reassured them
that the central bank was on top of it
okay guys i just want to make sure don't
worry about it he's on top of it
everything's going to be all right he's
reassuring the rest of us
so how bad right now we got 5.4
what number you think it'll peak at i
believe that we have a 10 to 15 percent
inflation year in progress
a 10 to 15 percent so damn straight
because they'll announce 10 or 15
no hell node it's just like labor
statistics they're going to be
manipulated
but i believe it's there you can't find
me anybody with common sense
and you know what i don't care what
level of education you have
don't underestimate the man on the
street the average american
educated or not you know like college
educate whatever it is they understand
it they see what's going on rents are
going up because they're tied to housing
prices housing is going up because it's
tied
new housing they're just gonna walk
around the supermarket tom that that
they're gonna walk through
so hang on yeah now let's go to the
let's go to the two necessary parts of
the supermarket right
let's go back to produce and let's go
back to
dairy so look at a gallon of milk and go
look at what's happening there
i'm shocked that you know
the news media and politicians and that
was politico that actually used the word
spike with inflation and a headline you
know how careful they've been on
headlines all year
they're starting to see it i think the
average person on the street
good grief american airlines in delta
send you emails saying hey there's a
fuel shortage shortage means prices go
up and we paid a little bit more on the
php office renovation
these are just examples that we can talk
about around the table you go down to
starbucks and you conduct a survey with
the man on the street
you know what you're going to have
you're going to have people to tell you
oh when i just went to buy a car i can't
even get a car
oh the lease was going to be this this
is going to be this the average american
is seeing it and feeling it
even though the headlines have been
trying to make sure
that americans don't get too freaked out
about it i think we're at 10 to 15
right effing now pat we have a lot of
like younger viewers
that are just getting started right so
what how would you explain inflation to
them how would you explain inflation to
the 18 19 20 year old kid
how would you explain it to them in a
way that they can tangibly you know
understand what's going on without it
coming off as some like
esoteric scary uh you know economic term
all right like there's a guy he's just
starting his career wants to be an
entrepreneur he's getting in the sales
you talk about high school what age
could you talk about let's say the
bottom age of
the valuetainment demographic the people
that are just getting into starting to
to dip their toes in in politics
economics they're starting to think
about these things they're starting to
to to be curious about the world at
large how would you explain inflation we
talk about it a lot
but i don't really think people
understand the gravity of the situation
how would you explain inflation to them
i i you know it's very interesting my
youngest brooker who every now and then
is on the
case studies thank you very much so
she's going into fifth grade and
i gave her a simple example like this i
said you know that soda machine that i
hate that's at your school
and now it's got 20 ounce sodas in there
all that caffeine and sugar
yeah what if you walk by it one day it's
a dollar the next day you walk by it's a
dollar 25
right what is your allowance per week
she says well ten dollars but i have to
do this and this and this and this
i said that's right and what if i just
tell you that i'm only gonna keep paying
you ten dollars
yet you walk by the soda machine now
it's seven dollars a dollar twenty five
brooke that's inflation what i pay you
per week
now take a look at everything think of
it as gas we put in the car
all these things that's inflation broke
those prices go up and yet
you still make ten dollars a week your
little allowance but she has to do
things i don't just hand it out
and now we're entering you know so
there's the basics a lot of libertarians
are starting to throw the term
death spiral out where we're entering a
situation where the federal government
is advocating for higher taxes
wages are stagnant and you have
inflation and they're pumping dollars in
that the american consumer immediately
spends and sends straight to the bottom
line
people say how's the stock market up the
economies was so bad because we pumped a
bunch of money into the consumer's
pocket
they spent it on things and it lands on
the bottom line and it's supporting the
stock market there's actually somebody
here who lived through inflation right
vanessa you you were in
in venezuela right yeah it's not fun
runaway inflation what what was it like
what year were you there
i left on 2012
so that was before chavez was still
alive
but my mom was like i feel like she says
that somehow
she's like you're out of here and then a
few years later he went
downhill yeah so it was already happened
in the inflation that's when it started
and then it got really bad
yeah and then they had to turn off
electricity sometimes and things turn
off water
and then chavez got sick and then he
died right yes correct so this was at
the beginning of it your mom saw it
coming
and got you out yes this was you know so
people don't understand the price of
bread was just to use american terms it
was like one dollar
and the next day was two dollars a week
later it was ten dollars and then it was
a thousand dollars
a month later like a bread could be like
a million dollars now
for a loaf of bread wait what'd you say
a bread
a loaf of bread compared to dollars
currency can be a million dollars
a loaf of bread is a million dollars in
venezuela yeah
do you know the conversion u.s one
dollar venezuela it goes
up so fast that i stopped
yeah that that that's that's wow that's
society
that's the end of society why would
anybody ever play by society's rules at
that point
then it just becomes survival of the
fittest you go back to you know feudal
warlords
the biggest the biggest thing work where
i'm happy about is the following let me
tell you what i'm happy about and not
happy about but
i'm glad it's predictable anything
that's unpredictable is quite scary
things that are predictable to me
you actually pulled it up i don't even
know what number dear god
oh my god 398 billion dollars to buy
yeah it does work 400 billion dollars is
one dollar
yeah both of ours 400 million bolivar
to one and any of us in the united
states do you remember when the peso was
crazy
you would you would take 10 in the
united states you would go down to
tijuana
and you were given like 200 000 pesos
remember
and gum was like 50 000. but let me say
this let me let me say this part the
part that gives me confidence to follow
it
if i do something wrong there should be
repercussions to it
so the best thing is that inflation is
happening
for the american people to realize the
next time you say yes to just printing
money for the hell of it
know that this is the consequences you
just have to know if you say yes to this
this is what's coming so maybe a
temporary you know
relief or whatever maybe but you have to
face this year right now with the
inflation that uh
and by the way you know who inflation
benefits who who wins from inflation
the poor the middle class or the rich
who wins from inflation wealthy
the rich rich always win and by the way
who causes inflation the wealthy
who causes inflation government the
government responding to the policies
that the rich want yeah so it's it's the
actually they don't always want it but
the government causes inflation so you
said the rich the wealthy uh cause
inflation or the government causes
inflation i don't think that there's a
distinction between the two anymore
so you think the rich are the government
i don't think i think that
i call it the ivy league cabal it's
there's a very very clear
there's a very to me a very clear group
of particularly ivy league educated
people they all come from the same
schools
they all go into the same groups and
they want
a global government and they want a
global economy i don't think anything
that's happening right now has caught
any of these people by surprise
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye